thanks everyone coming hope you're
having a good conference I know I'm
having a ton of fun over at the rapids
booth up on the sixth floor
so I'm Keith Krause I'm one of the
maintainer of Rapids
I'm a engineering manager at Nvidia I
work most heavily on our ku DF library
which I'll talk about later but we're
really excited about kind of
accelerating the data science ecosystem
and the PI data ecosystem using GPUs and
so kind of one of one of the reasons we
kind of looked at this ecosystem and
thought hey we can kind of take
advantage of GPUs and parallel computer
hardware is kind of we looked at the
history of kind of how people have been
doing data processing and so if we go
back say like 10 years from now everyone
kind of at skill was using Hadoop and it
looked something like this where
everything was on disk you would read
from disk do some type of query write to
disk read back from disk do some slicing
and dicing of your data right to disk
read from disk again and then do some
type of training or modeling or other
type of work and then SPARC came around
and kind of most people that cared about
performance moved over to spark and the
big thing was hey SPARC is primarily in
memory it was kind of 25 200 X
improvements less code everything was
kind of easier and faster for you and
now fast-forward 10 years today and
we're kind of at this point where we're
starting to see the bottlenecks that
come up in kind of just the CPU based
in-memory computing and that basically
this is a really simple query of just a
like group by count and you can see here
that basically once the data is in
memory in the nice in-memory format just
doing something simple like that will
actually just completely bottleneck at
the CPU and this is kind of after your
data has been parsed after you do all
the kind of nasty cleaning of your data
and other things before you actually run
this type of analytical query and those
are a lot more complicated typically a
more CPU intensive than these and so
that bottleneck gets even worse as your
comp as your workload becomes more
complex
and so kind of if you look at deep
learning in other fields people started
to look at hey GPUs have lots of compute
power maybe I can use them to accelerate
these types of workloads and it ended up
looking something like this where you
your data still lives in the data lake
or wherever it sits in a DBMS or
something you have kind of a one-time
expensive read and then you move it over
to the GPU and all of a sudden you can
do that work a lot faster but then you
end up writing it back to system memory
in order to kind of go hand it off to
your next tool and so for example in the
GPU world you could imagine that oh I've
got some kind of like GPU database and I
run a query that query returns really
fast but then I send the data back to
system memory either as like a pandas
dataframe or an umpire array only for
then another application to read in that
data copy it back to the GPU and
basically the same format that it
started on do its work and repeat the
same process and basically what you see
is yeah you get like a 5 to 10x
improvement there but it ends up being
way more code way more complex way more
rigid and you're losing most of your
performance from those kind of
intermediate steps and just doing
unnecessary copies and conversions of
data but a lot of people ask like so why
why would I use GPUs like why why did
GPUs make sense for data science and
data analytics and it comes down to a
few different hardware advantages so
kind of when people hear of GPUs most
people think of like oh I'm gonna be
doing big dense matrix multiplies GPUs
are actually very general-purpose
computing Celler aters they've
essentially just got thousands of cores
so like modern high-end GPUs can get up
to 15 teraflops of kind of
general-purpose computer formance and
then another 10 20x that for like deep
learning specific performance but then
on top of that you've got up to a
terabyte a second a memory bandwidth per
GPU Hardware interconnects that go up to
like 300 gigabytes a second of
bi-directional GPU to GPU bandwidth and
then you can actually just scale up to
like 16 GPUs in a single node as opposed
to having to scale out when you want
more sockets
and kind of wanted one of the key
takeaways here is I talked about kind of
a terabyte a second memory bandwidth the
15 teraflops actually is just like
infinitely more than that memory
bandwidth where you essentially almost
never run out of compute relative to
your memory bandwidth and so what that
means is that you essentially you end up
with this new kind of programming
mindset where you're not optimizing to
do the compute in the smartest and most
efficient way possible you optimized to
minimize your data movement and minimize
your memory copies because those end up
being your most expensive thing and so
kind of going back to the original
diagram this is what it would look like
to use kind of two GPU accelerated
applications application a and B the the
fastest way to optimize this isn't to
optimize the compute that a and B are
doing it's to eliminate everything in
the middle here which ends up like
entirely becoming your bottleneck and
you spend more than half the time just
in those copy and conversions and so
kind of as as Rapids was starting it
before Rapids there was the GPU open
analytics initiative Apache Aero was
growing at the same time and so Apache
Aero is a really really exciting
open-source project that a combination
of the PI data ecosystem the Apache Big
Data ecosystem are kind of standardizing
around to define standard memory layouts
to allow different technologies
different programming languages to
efficiently share memory between them
and then to eventually run efficient
compute on top of it and one of the
things that they basically really were
trying to solve is hey I don't want to
have to constantly serialize and
deserialize my data and convert things
to move kind of between different stages
in a data pipeline and so kind of
learning from Apache arrow rapids builds
entirely on top of Apache arrow with the
idea of sharing GPU memory between
different technologies and so you can
see here that essentially you go from
those constant CPU writes CPU writes CPU
reads CPU read to you do a one-time read
to get data into GPU memory and then you
can essentially just go through your
whole pipeline and just share the GPU
memory
that pipeline and kind of once once you
do that and you have that working you
see some like amazing real-world
benefits and so this is this is like a
real world a real world workflow of
essentially modifying uh sorry excuse me
modeling credit risk basically is
someone going to default on their
mortgage and it basically involves
loading a bunch of kind of gross CSV
data doing some slicing and dicing
feature engineering on the data and then
essentially training an extra boost
model to say hey is this person going to
default or not and basically you can see
here that with single DG x2 which is a
16 GPU box or 5/8 GPU boxes we can get
massive massive massive speed ups on the
end-to-end data pipeline by doing it all
on the GPU and kind of just to put in
perspective rapids where at we just
released zero point ten a few weeks ago
we'll be releasing zero point eleven in
mid-december it's just over a year old
at this point it launched back in
October of 2018 and it's improving over
time stone that you can see that we're
still over the past year we've gotten
basically another 50 X or sorry 50
percent performance there's still a lot
of room for optimization there's a lot
more room to make this faster so we're
really excited by the potential of this
ecosystem and just to kind of share from
Frank Washlet one of the kiosks he very
involved in Karis intenser flow
basically what he was saying is that the
people who win at data science are those
who basically have the most iteration
cycles that essentially it's a
combination of speed and user experience
in order for the developers and data
scientist to just get as much iteration
with their data as possible in order to
build the best results so we're here
talking about Rapids and kind of before
you get into Rapids this is this is PI
data we're talking about the PI data
ecosystem and so this is a super
high-level picture of what the PI data
ecosystem
look like that in general you have some
type of pipeline that looks like data
preparation which includes things like
loading data some ETL some future
engineering into then some modeling into
some visualization and then you have a
feedback loop in there that basically
everyone goes through this type of loop
of hey I've got data I want to draw
insights from it this is the pattern of
how people draw insights and then people
use libraries like panda scikit-learn
Network acts your deep learning
framework of choice map outlet Seabourn
bouquet etc now kind of what we're doing
with Rapids is basically trying to
enable users of this pi data ecosystem
to be able to take advantage of GPU
acceleration and accelerated Hardware
without having to completely rethink how
they work without having to learn lower
level programming that basically ku DF
essentially is a pandas like library who
ml is a scikit-learn like library ku
graph follows the network X API and is
graph analytics library and then of
course there's GPU accelerated deep
learning frameworks and you can continue
to use your data visualization framework
of choice but so kind of this talk is
about
how do we scale for like
high-performance data science at scale
and we we actually scale using desk and
so kind of for those of you who aren't
familiar with tasks tasks is a
distributed python task graph framework
and kind of distributed computing j'en
and what's really great about it is it's
PI data native so I know Eric Dale gave
a talk yesterday about combinate like
basically SPARC tasks Rapids etc desk
from a Python perspective desk just like
very naturally plugs into this ecosystem
that I can continue to write kind of my
high level Python and very naturally
just describe what I want to accomplish
as a set of tasks for GPUs and for the
rapid ecosystem task is great because
it's extremely modular
that for example - dataframe use used
pandas dataframes underneath as its
compute layer because we followed the
pandas api it was really easy for us to
say hey let's have let's work with the
dance community to have them target
pandas like AP is that anyone who
basically follows the pandas api enough
can plug in as a compute layer
underneath vast data frame and then all
of a sudden hey you've got
gpu-accelerated - data frames at that
point also the fact that it is Python
native as opposed to for example
something like spark that has the JVM in
the middle it makes it really easy to
get to access things like C++ C and CUDA
related code which gives us a lot of
flexibility to give kind of you as
end-users of data scientists data
engineers and developers the most
powerful tools for you to solve your
problems and one of the things that
we're really excited that we're kind of
working with the task community to
contribute is basically the ability to
use lower level transport mechanisms
than TCP so there's this great open
source library called open UC X it's a
community driven effort between nvidia
AMD Mellanox arm IBM a few dition
national labs a few different
universities but the idea is basically
building a communication abstraction
library that can take advantage of any
hardware fast paths
fast paths available on systems and so
for desk
what this means is that if I'm working
with GPU memory all of a sudden I could
take advantage of Hardware interconnects
between GPUs and get 150 gigabytes a
second between GPUs within a node or hey
say say I've just got like some gaming
GPUs and I don't have hardware
interconnects I still have the PCI
Express bus that I can copy things over
without having to go back to the CPU to
go back to the GPU and there I can still
get like 16 gigabytes a second give or
take and then say oh I've got like a big
cluster and I've got the money for like
really powerful networking for that
cluster we can take advantage of things
like InfiniBand and our DMA over
Ethernet to kind of get peak throughput
and
what's what's really exciting is that
even if there you have no specialized
hardware whatsoever you need to send
over a one Gigabit Ethernet link it will
have a TCP fallback but all of the
memory management and TCP handling is
moved underneath the Python layer and so
we can still provide speed ups there as
well and it will work for CPU memory as
well as GPU memory so basically for for
anyone using tasks with anything like
pandas dataframes numpy rays this is
really exciting because it's going to
make the communication a lot faster and
for GPUs were super excited because
it'll make the communication like 100x
faster than TCP and so kind of the high
level picture is that you know PI data
super productive API is super friendly
user experience for people people are
super productive with it if you need to
scale up using PI data use rapids and
then when you need to scale out you can
use desk and Rapids with desk in order
to scale out and basically the whole
idea here is everything in this kind of
ecosystem basically has the same api's
and same end user experience where you
write the same high level code that
you're used to writing to solve your
problems as opposed to worrying about
distributed systems problems or how do i
target the specific parallel hardware so
let's dive into some of the libraries so
first let's talk about qu TF which is
our GPU accelerated data frame library
and so when we were first building this
a lot of people basically asked like do
we really need GPU accelerated ETL like
do people care about that and the answer
is yes that the average data scientist
spends like 90 plus percent of their
time in just dealing with their data and
slicing and dicing their data and
cleaning their data and doing feature
engineering as opposed to training
models and kind of one of one of our
designers actually threw this together
that basically with CPUs it's very
common that people essentially kick off
a job go grab a cup of coffee hope for
the best come back to see oh I forgot to
add a feature or something broke make a
small change kick off another job go
grab some more coffee
and kind of where where we're trying to
go with GPUs is to basically what you're
running like what you're running today
and batch we want to move to be
interactive that you know if things are
going to blow up let's blow up fast so
that you can immediately iterate and fix
things and as much as maybe data
scientists won't be happy about it let's
try to curb the caffeine addiction so
kind of this is this is what the
technology stack of ku DF looks like so
there is a Python high level API looks
and feels like pandas very quickly
underneath there there is a scythe on
layer to basically bind to C++ api's
there is a full C++ library that you can
use directly if you'd like if you want
to go lower than the Python and then
underneath that C++ library it basically
builds on top of the years of software
investment in the CUDA and NVIDIA
ecosystem so libraries like thrust Cobb
Jeddah Fayette cetera to basically take
full advantage of the hardware available
and so Lib ku DF I said is basically the
CUDA C++ library this contains all of
the guts of the implementation so
everything as far as doing all of like
the element wise math things like
sorting joins group bys reductions
basically anything that you could think
of as being like compute heavier
expensive lives in Lib qu DF and again
there is a full-featured C++ API if
you'd want to use that directly then ku
DF is the Python library on top of that
that basically exposes the pandas API
that user most end users kind of expect
and want to work with and it basically
integrates nicely into the PI data
ecosystem where you can kind of hand it
the typical things you would hand like
numpy arrays any kind of like python
iterable etc it and then we also do some
kind of fun things with just-in-time
compiling user-defined functions so that
your apply functions that normally slow
down quite a bit and pandas are no
longer very painful and I'll pull up a
Jupiter notebook and we'll play around
with that a little bit and so just some
just some like quick easy benchmarks
this is a easy benchmark 5
five columns of in 32 data 10 million
rows and 100 million rows and you can
see that cou DF we get some really huge
speed ups over pandas and that kind of
merged like a join sorting group I
depending on the operation we can get
more speed up it's very it's very
operation dependent but you'll typically
see in like the worst case we get about
a 10x and in the best case it's like
more than a thousand X but you know not
not everything is data frames so we have
a full string library as well on the GPU
and so this kind of exposes the things
that you would typically think of doing
especially when you get into kind of the
gross ETL and of having to deal with all
kinds of weird string data so we've got
a regular expression engine all of your
typical element wise operations you can
run group bys and joins on strings
there's full categorical columns with
both the values and categories on the
GPU that essentially instead of relying
on Python objects we have a native
string type within cootie F and there
it's it's pretty fast
kind of coming coming in future releases
we're actually optimizing strings
further that it was originally built as
a side library to Crewe DF it's moving
into ku DF and becoming more natively
built into ku DF and Lib ku DF and kind
of with that we're also exploring hey
how could we do just-in-time compiled
string UDF's which is a very tricky
problem and kind of something something
I think is amazing and what really made
me think wow Rapids is real is we have a
set of GPU accelerated readers and
writers and so you can see kind of basic
code snippet on the right here we have a
GPU accelerated CSV reader and it'll
typically get like 15 to 25 X / pandas
and depending depending on exactly your
types if you rely on type inference or
not that number can vary quite a bit but
we also have a park a reader an orc
reader JSON reader Avro reader we have a
CSV
we have an orc writer as of 0.10 and a
park a writer will be coming in the next
release as well and kind of one that one
of the keys here in order for us to kind
of drive these speed ups is handling as
much on the GPU as possible so if you
essentially give us a compressed file we
will actually just send those compressed
bytes to the GPU do decompression on the
GPU do all of the parsing on the GPU and
then return you data frame on the GPU
and basically because we do everything
on the GPU it saves us the bandwidth and
getting data to the GPU and then
basically we don't get CPU bottlenecked
and just trying to load data which
actually as you can see can be a pretty
big bottleneck in a lot of situations
and there is a there's an announced but
not yet released technology called GPU
direct storage that is really exciting
that will basically allow you to bypass
the CPU entirely for loading data and
basically just go over basically talk to
you nvme drives either locally or over a
fabric and get even more bandwidth to
the GPU that way as of now basically so
like say you ran this code what it's
going to do is run a mem map under the
hood and then copy those bytes to the
GPU in general because it lives on a say
it lives just on a local disk there no
matter what you have to read the data
into memory first to send it to the GPU
somewhere with nvme because nvm ease
live on the pci express bus with GPUs we
can actually kind of be smarter and
figure out oh here's the like
essentially address range on the item
that nvme that we want to read the
memory from and just copy it over the
PCI Express bus to the GPU without ever
having to go back to the CPU and back
down no this is this is without the
technology and so there'll be even more
speed ups when we integrate that so
Rapids in general only runs on Linux as
of now but other than that there it's
not like distro dependent or anything
like that obviously if you have if you
have like a crowded PCI Express topology
then you'll have less bandwidth and that
will affect things but
it in general you typically see this
like 10 15 X 25 X type speed up for CSV
but also I haven't done any benchmarking
myself but I've also heard that that
work writer is amazing and that someone
was saying that they got like a 50 X
over sparks or greater so I'd say check
that out too
the team that works on these this kind
of like IO reading writing stuff is
amazing they're they're crazy and this
is this is really what sold me like okay
if they can parse CSV these on GPU they
can probably do most things on the GPU
because that is not something that you
would think of as like a traditional GPU
type problem so but yet ETL ETL isn't
just data frames and so kind of PI data
ecosystem people use numpy arrays all
over and numpy is kind of like the
standard for hey here's how I interact
with array data in GPU land that's a
little bit more complicated of a story
because there isn't just one numpy
library there's actually about 15
different GPU Python array libraries and
there isn't like one winner by any means
and so we've been doing a lot of work to
essentially just build bridges in this
ecosystem to allow all of these
different GPU accelerated libraries to
just share memory between one another
zero copy and so what that means for you
as a user is you can essentially combine
all of these libraries together and just
chain function calls from all of these
libraries and literally it's just
pointer sharing to basically handle GPU
memory under the hood and so for example
I do I load some data using KU DF I do
some slicing and dicing of my data I can
then hand that to something like PI
torch 0 copy and immediately inference
or train on it and basically save a ton
of time and memory by doing that so the
other thing like so we talked about
numpy there is there's GPS array
libraries I'm using coop I here's an
example because they most closely follow
the numpy or API but coop I can
basically drive huge speed up similar to
kudia
for irate type things and so this is
kind of some simple benchmarks things
like FFTs array slicing matrix
multiplication that you can get big
speed ups there as well and then for
things like SPD's you can see that
basically excuse me scaling going from
essentially all of the CPUs in a big box
this is like a dual twenty a dual twenty
core box a single GPU you'll get like a
typical like a 2x over a dual twenty
core and then it will scale up to like 8
or more GPUs and we'll do we'll do some
examples of doing an SVD in a little
while in a notebook and just like kind
of a fun thing for example generating
generating random data and then actually
running like an aggregation across that
data that basically using 80 GPUs you
can do 3.2 petabytes of data in less
than an hour for example and the key
thing here is this is all working in
high-level Python api's without any CUDA
magic ninja wizardry anything that you
write the same numpy like api's and
basically combination of like desk coupe
I take advantage of the hardware
transparently to you as an end user and
just some other videos that you can see
kind of some of how how Rapids use his
tasks to scale up and scale out I would
definitely say watch them they're quick
little things but really cool so we
talked about we talked about machine
learning as well that people use SK
learn PI data ecosystem we have an open
source library called KU ml which is
basically follows the scikit-learn api
and kind of the problem is that
basically what we see is people people
want to train models to drive insights
of their data but they end up with just
more and more data where they're
modeling techniques can't handle it and
so then they end up in this place where
they do sampling they try to remove
outliers they do dimensionality
reduction feature selection essentially
they they just use more and more
techniques to try to reduce the amount
of data that they're
dealing with in order to actually be
able to run their model their modeling
in a timely fashion to actually drive
valuable insights so Kumail looks kind
of similar to look similar to qu TF that
basically Python scythe on full-featured
C++ library I do want to point out that
we there is something called qu ml prims
which is essentially a set of math
primitives used for building machine
learning algorithms and so it will it'll
have things like distance functions and
kind of other like linear algebra type
primitives that are very commonly used
in building these machine learning
algorithms and we expose those
primitives where hey if there's like
something you want to do different than
like that's not just like a normal
straightforward algorithm you don't need
to reinvent all of that low-level
complicated math and like doing that on
the GPU isn't necessarily trivial you
can essentially just compose your
algorithm of these primitives and get
really really good performance from
doing so and so kind of just high-level
picture of what ku ml looks like today
we have a bunch of algorithms so far in
0.10 things like we recently released
random forests and we have a multi node
multi-gpu random forest implementation
that we're really excited about
definitely go try it out but things like
clustering k-means DB scan you map etc
it's really really really exciting that
basically if if you use these algorithms
via scikit-learn today and I would I
would really encourage you go check it
out try it let us know how it works and
just to kind of give an example what it
looks like so kind of run something like
this on the CPU that you import from
scikit-learn you import something import
DB scan and then you run like fit and
predict and then to do it with ku mel
and KU TF it's literally just an import
change at that point and it runs the
exact same way it will handle GPU inputs
it will handle like your typical numpy
array and cpu-based inputs as well
and you can see again we get some pretty
great speed ups over
scikit-learn and that we we stop at four
million rows and like 64k array size
that if we get any larger it just it
becomes really really difficult the
benchmark because psychic learning
starts taking a long time but we're
really we're really really excited so
and we also have a forest inferencing
library where if you're using something
like extra boost or like GBM or like
scikit-learn RF basically we have this
inferencing library where you can feed
it any of these trained models it's a
super lightweight easy to use python api
that basically can give you a like 20 to
35 X speed up in your inferencing and so
kind of this is this is what it looks
like today as of our latest release in
October so we have we have some multi
node multi-gpu algorithms we have a few
multigp algorithms we have a lot of
single GPU algorithms and kind of where
we're trying to we're trying to be by
March of 2020 for 0.13 release is be
here that kind of all moulting a bunch
of multi node multi-gpu algorithms so I
mentioned we have a graph analytics
library as well and kind of what some of
the goals benefits really really high
performance and so for example we say up
to 500 million edges here on a single
GPU that it's really like up to 2
billion edges give or take we want to
expose a property graph support via kind
of KU DF data frames so basically you
can hand data frames in get data frames
out and run like a query like graph
query like things against it and that
basically same principle of a really
high level Python API that will follow
Network X but then a full C++ API that
exposes more granular things if you wish
to use it as an end user and kind of
similar similar technology stack again
though I will say that there there was
already a few really great GPU
accelerated graph analytics frameworks
but they the big struggle was that they
didn't solve the data pipeline problem
where essentially you as an end-user
needed to go and construct like
compressed C++ objects in order to use
them which is essentially like a
non-starter for most data scientist data
engineers and so we pipeline all of that
for you handle all of that on the GPU
where basically you can focus on just
using high-level algorithms to solve
your problems and you can see here we've
got a bunch of graph algorithms as well
we recently released a blog on multi-gpu
PageRank about running PageRank on I
think 300 gigabytes of data and it
running and I think like 20 seconds or
so I would seriously say check it out I
know before Nvidia I was at a
cybersecurity lab we're running running
being able to run PageRank on a large
amount of data very fast was the dream
to build essentially a time series of
graph features to then feed into kind of
more traditional ml and DL and so the
fact that kind of we can actually do
that at scale now is super super
exciting and you can see here not not
the best benchmark because it's Network
X which definitely trades performance
for ease of use but you can see we get
basically huge speed ups even on some of
these smaller graphs that are only like
a few hundred thousand nodes and edges
and kind of like I said we released a
blog of this recently but essentially 16
billion edges 400 million vertices that
we essentially were able to do it and I
think under a minute
essentially for running page PageRank
and so kind of this is this is what it
looks like today that we've got a bunch
of single GPU algorithms PageRank is the
first multi-gpu algorithm that we've
released for graph and kind of where
where we're shooting to go by march have
a personal PageRank multi-node multi-gpu
have a breadth-first search multimodal
multi-gpu and have some additional
single GPU algorithms we also have a
recently really recently released open
source geospatial library
it's definitely it's definitely earlier
we're seeing like huge performance
improvements that it's getting like a
thousand x over like G doll which is
kind of one of the reference geospatial
libraries we're still very much figuring
out what the Python API should look like
for this so it's still a little bit
early if you're interested in geospatial
analysis please give it a shot raise an
issue tell us that this API makes no
sense you should follow this API or
consider this we really really love
feedback to help kind of drive what this
should look like for us but basically as
it as it stands today there is a there's
a full C++ library API there's a Python
API on top of that and it integrates
nicely into the rest of the rapid
libraries where basically you can hand
it KU TF data frames immediately runs
some type of geospatial analysis like
point and polygon get a KU DF data frame
pack and continue on with your analysis
and data and never needs to leave the
GPU so yeah and so kind of like we're
where we are today we've got a point in
polygon a few different distance
calculations like have assigned distance
ha storage distance lat lon
transformations etc and kind of where
we're going is kind of a lot a lot more
of kind of different geospatial indexing
techniques kind of different geospatial
clustering type things but again any
feedback that you have as users into
kind of what geospatial problems you're
struggling to solve today that you would
love some more horsepower to solve would
be super helpful for us to kind of
define what this development roadmap
should look like and so just some like
really brief some really brief
performance numbers that basically they
point in polygons we can see here we get
like a 300 300 X over a optimize C++
implementation and that if we use like
the Python Shapley library I don't even
know it one millisecond 230,000
milliseconds it's yeah and then for
things like distance calculations again
we get huge speed ups as well
so I want to make it clear like Rapids
Nvidia contributes heavily to Rapids we
really believe in building this
open-source GPU ecosystem but NVIDIA is
by no means that like sole contributor
to Rapids that there is a number of
contributors across companies like
anaconda blazing sequel preferred
networks who does cheyna and coop I UC
Davis for gunrock Wan site Walmart and
that a bunch of people are using it
already as well and kind of we we work
with a lot of open source communities as
well to kind of help drive both the
rapids ecosystem and the general PI data
ecosystem and make sure that we're
aligned in how we move forward and so
kind of along with the like core rep its
libraries there's people building on top
of Rapids now and kind of just to
highlight a few streams is a it's a
Python stream processing framework that
it was originally built for using pandas
and asked to do stream processing but
because we followed pandas API we've
done a little bit of work to make it
more general-purpose and so it can
target ku DF as well and we're really
excited to kind of continue driving
stream processing through their new Clio
is a serverless it's like a service
event platform and basically they've
they're utilizing Rapids to kind of GPU
accelerate data processing under it
where typically they would CPU
bottleneck and using either panda source
Park and that with GPUs they can
actually just basically get like Nick
line rate at that point and one of the
ones I'm really excited about is blazing
sequel which is essentially an open
source sequel engine that uses the same
lib crude EF C++ library as the KU TF
pandas lake library and so basically the
idea is that you get to just write
sequel and their inputs and outputs or
things like kudiye for - qdf data frames
and so it just naturally plugs into your
data pipeline entirely and they actually
just recently released a blog where they
were they ran a few of the T PCH scale
factor 100 queries and their results are
very very good where the majority of the
time I'll
sorry not the majority but a non-trivial
amount of time is actually just loading
data from cloud storage or local nvme
drives which is a pretty good place to
bottleneck considering and kind of just
to give you an example of what it looks
like it's a kind of it's just a Python
library that kind of plugs in naturally
into the PI data ecosystem that
essentially you just point it to point
it to your data whether that's local or
in some type of cloud store and then run
sequel and then calling dot get returns
at ku DF data frame at that point and
then you can proceed to use any other
library that integrates in this
ecosystem from there and kind of as I
mentioned earlier with nucleo building
on top of it basically enabling
serverless type functionality with GPUs
as well and so Rapids is kind of
everywhere at this point it's it's crazy
it's crazy for my perspective but it's
in essentially all of the major clouds
at this point Google Amazon sure Alibaba
Baidu etc that basically wherever you
run your data analysis today Rapids is
essentially there and if it's not let us
know and we will try to work to get it
there for you
and so Rapids it's all open source it's
all in github github calm rapids ai we
publish condo packages that you can just
go Conda install any of these libraries
and then we also publish docker image
docker images both on docker hub and NGC
and if you go to the rapid AI website
excuse me there is a really easy kind of
installation thing where you can
basically say hey I want Conda or I want
docx or I want to do from source what
packages do I want what Python version
what CUDA version and it will basically
generate you the command to install very
nice and tidy see I go check out the
github everything everything is
open-source we also have we have a few
different repos of kind of notebooks and
community notebooks and tutorials that
are really helpful as far as getting
started if you're familiar with the PI
data ecosystem they'll feel really
boring because it
looks and feels like the libraries that
you're used to using except everything
just returns faster so if you want to
check out we have some like ten-minute
getting started guides and API Doc's at
stock Stott Rapids day.i we also try to
blog quite a bit they a combination of
like hey what's new in the libraries
that we're releasing and like here's
some like some cool problem that someone
worked on using Rapids or like hey
here's some cool thing that someone
built on top of Rapids check out the
blog on medium and kind of I mentioned
that we have we have a notebooks and a
notebooks contribute oh that has
examples tutorials we even have there's
a cog Oh Grand Master on our team who
kind of just goes around trying to win
cago competitions using Rapids and he
typically publishes all of his notebooks
if you're interested in that kind of
stuff the some of the stuff he does is
wild I would definitely check it out
it's really cool we've also started
recently releasing kind of like short
casts on YouTube it's kind of like
walking through what it looks like to
use some of the rapids libraries and
explaining how some of the things work
under the hood where it's definitely
helpful this is it's an open source
community nvidia obviously we have a
long history in developing
gpu-accelerated software the Python open
source ecosystem is definitely something
that we're newer to and we we really
need help from the community as far as
driving what the direction should look
like for some things that we we really
want to help solve your problems but we
really depend on feedback from users in
order to understand
hey what algorithm or what feature
should we prioritize next in order for
you to solve your problems and kind of
along with that any any type of
contribution is very appreciated issues
feature requests PRS blogs anything we
were really we're really excited about
growing this community and kind of we we
are one we are one community in a larger
open-source data science community and
we we do our best to work with these
communities and so kind of join join the
data science movement that we work
closely with the Apache
our project we will work closely with
the dice community the GP open analytics
initiative community just any any way
that you can kind of join the community
and help it's really appreciated and so
with that let's do some fun demo stuff
so if everyone can pray to the demo gods
all right
so just to kind of show a little bit
let's let's see here all right so I have
like typical notebook like environment
here just running in Jupiter lab we have
a couple we have a couple widgets that
basically just allow us to easily track
GPU memory and GPU utilization and we're
just going to do kind of some little
typical things like we would normally do
in pandas and so for example I'm just
going to use numpy generate some random
data yes I have a kernel all right so
just generate a little bit of random
data sign that into the data frame and I
can call head-on my data frame and cool
now you know what let's do the same with
a cou DF data frame instead of a panda's
data frame that okay assign that to ku
DF data frame call head awesome this
looks the same
but you know and so we did this with we
did this with ten million rows here but
you know what let's let's have a little
bit of fun
instead of using numpy I'm going to use
coop I to generate random data and you
know what led to generate a hundred
million rows instead of ten million here
so we're gonna use coop I generate 100
million rows and then assign those into
the GPU data frame here and so basically
I'm assigning these three coupie arrays
as different columns in my data frame
and then I'm deleting the reference to
those original coop arrays and the
reason I'm doing this is that
essentially the ku DF data frame here
will actually just zero copy reference
the the memory underneath so the same
coupe array and so when that ku DF data
frame goes out of scope I want that
memory to be freed and not be held by
those GPU Rand objects that I created
so I created create the cou TF data
frame and you can see here it created in
1.1 milliseconds because I'm just a zero
copy sharing memory and so now it's
let's do some typical things that we
would do for ETL so for example running
like a join the emerge so you can see
here running that with pandas running
ten million rows I'm just joining
against itself so it'll basically
roughly double the data so you can see
okay during ten million rows against
itself took about five seconds my output
is about twenty million rows and now
let's run the same thing with cout TF
okay so you see we ran the join about
four hundred milliseconds give or take
and it spit out 200 million rows from
there and we can do kind of some other
typical things like hey I want to sort
my data frame by that column a and run
that via pandas run it via cou DF and
you can see it's basically the same high
level API we're doing ten times the data
here in qu DF as we're doing with Dan
with panda so you can see we're still
getting speed ups and depending on the
operation we can get big speed ups not
as big of speed ups we can do we can do
kind of like the typical things that you
would do with math for example just
adding two columns together and you can
see again we can 10x the data we can
still get more than 10x in a lot of
situations here this is something I'm
really excited about in that hey I have
something that isn't like isn't there
like cleanness to expose via like pandas
built-ins let's actually use a UDF for
it and so I can define a simple function
like my UDF here and then run this via
panda supply and this is not the most
pleasant experience because what ends up
happening is this executes in Python
land at this point and it's like doing
it via iteration so so you see took 11
seconds there on 10 on like 20 million
rows give or take you know what let's do
now it's do the same thing with cou DF
there is a slight API difference that
we're working to fix right now hopefully
it should be fixed in the next release
but let's run this via CUDA
you can see it took 171 milliseconds
what's actually happening here is we
take this we take this my UDF we take
this UDF here and we actually pipeline
it through an open source project called
numba which is a just-in-time compiler
for python and so what happens here is
this function gets converted in to
vectorize GPU kernel and then we
basically just point that kernel to the
data that already lives on the GPU here
and just allocate an output and then
assign that to the data frame and
because we've kind of we have the
ability to share memory with all these
different libraries it makes it really
streamlined in order to be able to
integrate these things and combine these
different things and then you know just
to show kind of reading a CSV so we have
this we have a CSV file here I'm just
going to kind of show what it looks like
a little bit so you can see we have
everyone's favorite data set New York
City Taxi we have the 2016 month one
data and kind of its its New York City
Taxi data we can read that CSV via
pandas and then call describe on it and
you can see reading reading CSVs if
you're if you're interactively reading
CSV is it can kind of slow things down a
little bit
yep there we go so it took like 20 20
seconds give or take and then we can
read the same CSV once pandas describes
cool and then we can read the same CSV
via qu DF and you can see one point
seven five seconds exact same API is
that kind of you as an end-user can
basically use the exact same API is the
exact same type of workflow that you're
used to using and just get 10x hundred X
thousand X speed ups under the hood by
taking advantage of hardware I'm gonna
just restart this and and so we talked
we talked a little bit about tasks
earlier
yep
yeah no I'm not and like part of the
problem is doing this for the CPU it's
absolutely possible but at that like so
at this point you're because of the Pens
block manager you don't necessarily know
what the memory looks like here so I
could do for example I could do
something like PDF a dot values right
hmm I restarted my kernel but I could do
something like PDF a values here you
don't know if that's going to return by
zero copy or return by copy and if
that's a big column that's gonna be
expensive and so like your compute your
compute absolutely may be faster I agree
the compute may be faster but that
memory copy if that's large will be
really expensive and so it's like it's
kind of balancing I mean no matter what
I'm sure it will be better than dot
apply that being said it's also from an
API perspective it's not necessarily the
most straightforward that yeah I mean
it's also that for example I need to
then go through and rewrite my UDF that
I can't just write a nice like scaler
UDF here I need to like go through and
be like at JIT and then like instead of
passing a scalar here I need to pass an
array and then put a loop inside my
function so that number unrolls it and
everything from an end-user perspective
it's it's definitely a little trickier
there's nothing stopping a user from
doing that and I would say it's here I
want to just recreate a little bit here
there's nothing stopping you from doing
the same on the GPU side if you want
that type of control as well that for
example here so I've got got my GPU data
frame I've got this series here if I
reach inside of it I can actually get to
a number device right here and then from
there I can actually be like oh I want
my memory pointer and say I want to go a
step further I can even go down to hey
here is
I here is literally the the value of the
point like the UN pointer type on the
device so I can go feed this into a CUDA
kernel or whatever else I want to kind
of have complete and total control of
whatever I'm doing at this point
absolutely like but to a certain extent
like with Rapids we we've had an
interesting case where we've gotten a
community of GPU users where this is
their first time using Python at the
same time and so people that have never
used numpy and never use pandas I've
kind of come in and have been using ku D
F and ku PI and libraries like that and
they actually really like this because
they've got a whole bunch of legacy code
written in like CUDA and Fortran and C
that they can then easily pipeline this
through and so we we have we have like
so we have like the typical PI data data
science users we have this like new set
of GPU users who have never done Python
before that are trying this out where
essentially we want to expose everything
but this is exposed in a way where a
user really needs to dig to get to it
before they can like do something
dangerous at the same time so but like
kind of back to your original example of
using this someone could easily just get
that number device array and run a
number GPU kernel the same way as that
if they wanted but the API is just it
becomes a lot harder to do well and
there's a lot more potential for things
to crash and burn in doing so
for the implementations in general so we
I showed like a 0.2 in general there
hasn't really been a need to rework much
I would say that there's a major
refactor happening at the C++ library
right now but from an Python and users
perspective it's completely transparent
some of the like sometimes will optimize
things under the hood but again it's
it's like implementation details I would
say most of the churn comes from that
hey we had this API that like hid a
subset of the pandas API like for
example we only supported like two out
of seven keyword arguments and then
we'll go back and add the other five
keyword arguments to make it pandas
compliant and break our set like it'll
be a breaking change from like our
perspective but in a good way
if that makes sense and so I'd say that
that's that's where there's definitely
like the biggest amount of breakage
right now is just making API is more
pandas like if that makes sense
so yep yeah if if you can't compile it
number can't compile it to the GPU it's
something that you probably shouldn't
run on the GPU in general in which case
then I would say your option is to
essentially copy it back to the CPU and
run it there and so for example I can do
so here I can easily do like GD FA to
pandas and I've got a panda series that
I can then go do whatever I want with
oh yeah it'll it'll basically say hey I
can't compile this and then like
basically put it back on to you saying
basically saying I can't do this it's
back in your court as to what you want
to do yeah in in general we we do our
best to if it if it just like runs
nicely it'll run really fast and if it's
going to end up having to fall back to
something really slow that doesn't make
sense for the GPU we'd rather just throw
an exception that you can choose what to
do to do with does it what yes yeah so
it basically there's I'm sure there's
definitely still edge cases because CSV
is an abomination of a type that can
have anything and everything in it but
in general if we look here Shh we can
see but in general in general we do we
do test to make sure that our type
inference matches in like our known
cases to the best of our ability there
are situations where pandas does some
weird things when it comes to type
inference and we for example like there
might be some where while they return
like an n64 and we're like hey we can
actually return like a smaller Internet
and save you memory and make things
faster and we'll choose to do so and so
we can see here that basically
let's see
oh okay yeah way so if like we look in
64 objects and 64 float it basically
does all the same type inference it's
definitely faster if you specify data
types because then it doesn't need to
run extra logic in order to infer the
types but excuse me
in general we we do we do try our best
to match the type inferencing
capabilities and make sure that we're
not having weird behaviors when it comes
to types so yeah this is this is a
single box that I'm running on right now
and everything I showed here with single
GPU right now yeah this this all ran on
a single v100 the next thing I was a V
100 I don't remember it's the highest
it's like the current highest end GPU I
don't remember the exact price on it I
know it's thousands I don't remember how
many thousands what I will say is that
the T fours that are I think in every
cloud now are actually like amazing
value for this type of work the V 100's
have a lot of like deep learning
accelerator hardware in it that just
doesn't help with like this type of data
science work T fours basically as long
as you're doing single precision and
aren't doing double precision are
amazing because they have I want to say
like 60 percent the memory bandwidth and
compute of a V 100 and so sixty percent
of this type of performance is still
really good for a lot less cost that
there's a ton of value there yeah
yep
so I am an Nvidia employee having 95% of
the data science pipeline on video GPS
doesn't sound too bad to me but on it
like the the response I would give is
that a lot of people a lot of people ask
like why did you do this on top of CUDA
instead of like OpenCL or [ __ ] l and
the the answer to that is like OpenCL
[ __ ] l they like their open source but
everyone has their own proprietary
implementation and extensions of it that
basically makes it so no one can write
the same open CL or [ __ ] l - just
generally target hardware and you end up
needing to like go through and rework
everything depending on the hardware in
order to like actually take advantage of
the hardware nicely that in general
nvidia has put a ton of investment into
the like cuda software ecosystem and for
us it just like it absolutely doesn't
make sense to not take full advantage of
that investment that yeah no no I I mean
I get it it's just kind of exactly what
you said of like oh the entire pipeline
can run on NVIDIA GPUs that makes a
smile and throw our thumbs up so but
yeah I mean ultimately like our goal is
like so like Rapids is this open-source
GPU accelerated we're really excited by
it we contribute to it but our goal is
that we just really think GPUs are a
really good platform we're platform to
accelerate data science and basically we
want to we want to embrace and extend
that community and that doesn't
necessarily have to be through Rapids
that it could be it could be something
else that comes down the line that's
just like objectively better than what's
happening in Rapids right now and that's
great we just we really believe that
GPUs can really help accelerate these
types of workloads and then allow people
to kind of solve their problems more
effectively by doing so so
yeah
yep
yep
yeah yeah
yep yeah and I can say that kind of
before joining Nvidia I spent a lot of
time in the like Hadoop spark ecosystem
and I was really really tired of seeing
like heap exception errors and like my
driver dying because I ran out of heat
memory and so the fact that I'm like
back in the Python ecosystem and like
have like very strong control over
things it's a breath of fresh air from
my perspective yeah
[Music]
yeah whoa I'm not quite as in tune with
Kumail but I know that they were putting
a ton of effort into making sure that
you could essentially pickle - like
serialize the models similar like you
would do with scikit-learn and then be
able to load those models I believe a a
via via scikit-learn or via KHOU ml in
general and like making sure that it's
compatible to basically be able to
interoperate with the other ml libraries
in that way there's yeah there's there's
been there's been talk of it I think
it's definitely in like the earlier more
exploratory stage there's definitely
talks about how do we just like
essentially spit out like the vectors of
the weights and everything that can be
used to like recreate the model
essentially but I don't think that
there's like a strong consensus on
exactly what that should look like yet
but that's definitely something that we
were looking at and we're like looking
in the community to see what other
people are doing to try to figure out
how we can like do it in like the best
way to integrate with the community so
yeah yep yep no no like so I know for a
fact that you can basically train on a
machine and then export it and then use
Kumail to and fare on a different
machine and like I know because I know
that I'm almost positive that you can
like train on Kumail and then export to
then like predict using scikit-learn for
example I don't know I don't know if
like further than that if like there's a
generalized like how do we export this
model so that like anyone can go use it
type thing so
so just one other kind of quick fun demo
we showed a benchmark earlier about SVD
performance and I figure we can just run
it live and have some fun and hope it
doesn't break so we're gonna do first
basically we're just gonna we're gonna
do it on CPUs and I'm only using 10
cores here on purpose because the
basically desc SVD ends up calling into
numpy linear algebra library which is
already multi-threaded I believe and
someone can correct me if I'm wrong okay
I am wrong all I know is basically I've
spent a lot of time tuning this and the
more cores I throw out it the slower it
goes in running QR decomposition so yes
please correct me OK
gosh well note so to be clear this isn't
number this is whatever desks dasker a
linear algebra has to be the
implementation is which eventually calls
down to QR decomposition x' which I
assume just calls into numpy somewhere
and yeah yeah so yeah I'm almost
positive this is open Blas which I guess
is then I don't know all I know is if I
throw all more cores at it everything
slows down right now and so basically I
found that like ten was a general sweet
spot otherwise everything just kind of
hangs in the middle here so basically in
running basically you can see I just
generate a little bit of RAM data
actually pull up my desk thing here all
right so we're using a using a desk
plug-in here too that basically you can
see here so I've got I've got I
generated a whole bunch of random data
and basically what did I do
so I've got a million rows and then I
partitioned it so I've got him sorry I'm
a million by 1,000 matrix and then I
partitioned it into like 10,000 by 1,000
chunks and then running an SVD on it so
I basically I contributed the lazy the
generated the task graph basically when
I actually call persist it will trigger
the computation and so you can see here
wow this is let me change the theme here
maybe make it a little bit easier to see
right there we go it's a little bit
brighter at the cost being a little bit
blinding so you can see here basically
it's doing a bunch of QR decomposition
that it's not the one that I want to see
though
ah there you
okay so you can see we're doing we're
doing a bunch of QR decomposition x' but
generally this this will end up taking a
while will take a few minutes to run but
eventually I'll end up getting my result
I'm just going to I'm gonna stop this so
we don't have to wait for it alright so
now basically instead of just using a
numpy random state which is essentially
like just generating the random data we
are going to import coop I create a
local CUDA cluster and set it of a local
cluster and then use a coupie random
state and then basically do the exact
same code of calling the SVD and then
persisting it and you can see that it
finished and let me run that one more
time
alright so I've got I've got random data
basically call the SVD and then doing it
using coop I instead of numpy or desk
array and you can see basically the the
actual QR decomposition is just
accelerated so much by the GPU that we
can accelerate things quite a bit and
that if I can blow this up for a second
it's not what I want to do
so one thing that's really interesting
here test room kind of reset basically
at the end like you can see all of this
green here are like all the QR
decomposition 'z that are being run on
the GPU and then we have a whole bunch
of these red chunks here at the end that
are almost as long as the QR
decomposition and that's all of the
communication happening and I don't have
ucx running on this machine so this is
actually running through TCP and you can
see why
hey this communication actually takes as
long as all of the compute here and this
is why we really needed to accelerate
the communication under the hood for it
and so and so we're gonna do a little
bit of task who TF stuff and so kind of
we talked about we showed like using cou
DF it looks and feels like pandas
similar to dance data frame we have -
Koo DF and basically the idea of - Koo
DF is where there's gaps between kind of
- DF and pandas that we need to address
for desk we have small helpers but the
idea of the library is to eventually
just refactor itself out into unit tests
and that essentially will just
completely rely on the main line - code
entirely and work with the - community
to kind of make things friendlier for
GPUs in a way that also just helps in
general and so here I'm basically I just
defined a simple function to generate
some random data so I'm using Cooper to
generate some random data and
essentially I'm generating a hundred
million rows per task and then I'm
running two tasks per worker here and so
basically you can see okay so I've got
eight GPUs on this system you can see
okay each of them are using about five
gigabytes of their memory and then
okay and you can see they're kind of
going off doing a whole bunch of compute
and I've got a desk ku DF data frame and
it looks and feels like a dashed data
frame at this point similar to how you
would interact with CPUs and you can see
here basically I've got I've got 1.6
billion rows that I'm working with in a
data frame here and then I can do kind
of things that I would normally do like
okay call a group I and then get me the
sum and mean of a column and basically
you'll see it just nicely uses all the
GPUs and then returns me my results and
I can kind of do other things that used
to doing like hey here's like a rolling
window type calculation running and
there you go the idea the idea here
being that kind of you as an end-user
you right same high level pandas like
code that you're used to writing and we
figure out how to take advantage of GPU
hardware we we handle basically scaling
it for you that you just write the high
level code and we figure out how to make
everything work under the hood and how
to accelerate everything under the hood
for you so I think that's all that's all
I really wanted to show as far as demo
presentation what not none the demos
broke so thank you for praying to the
demo gods at this point I'll just take
any other questions that people have
yeah
hmm
yep yep yeah so it's like for example
for something where it's like hey you're
trying to iterate over data on the GPU
via Python will just blow up instead of
letting you do that because that's like
the absolute worst case of like
triggering a mem copy / like bite for
example which that would be that'd be
really bad in general yeah in general we
try to we try to like guard against
allowing you to do things that like a
real it'll give you like a 10,000 X
slowdown accidentally and then as far as
like profiling things go what we've seen
is that typically the most value we get
out of like the typical Python profiling
so just using like like C profile and
then like especially there's a library
called snake vis that's awesome
that gets us that gets us a lot of the
way there as far as like we can see okay
this is an issue in the Python or all of
our time is just in the C++ call at that
point and then so we get like the we get
the quick view there and if it's in the
Python great we can't we like we can
explore that profile and look at what we
need to do or if it's in C++ we go okay
we know it's in the C++ we need to
switch to a different profiling tool at
that point and at that point there is a
tool built into or its kind of shipped
alongside the CUDA toolkit called
insight compute which replaces and the
prof that it allows you to profile GPU
and CPU code and like put ranges into
the code and whatnot and shows like how
you're utilizing your hardware and where
time is being spent and whatnot and so
that's like the typical flow is we start
with snake VA's see if it like glaringly
shows anything if the C++ calls small
it's like great we know it's in Python
much just like dig into the profile and
profile here normally profile Python and
Explorer if the see if it's just like
all the C++ awesome let's just move to
the like more native profiling tool for
that low-level yep
yep yep Eric's talk yeah
yep yeah so we've looked at it we've
looked at it from like a couple of
perspectives from like a pure
performance perspective of like hey you
want to run the exact same workflow what
does your like hardware footprint cost
look like we typically see like a 90
plus percent TCO reduction even on cloud
yeah it's just ya know like so yeah like
we have we have sides like that but like
that's not this like I just want I want
to like nerd out about tech here so but
yeah like typically like for even with
cloud we see like 90 plus percent TCO
reduction typically that I think Mike
McCarty is giving a talk at GT CDC I
think tomorrow about capital ones
experience using desk and Rapids and I
think he has some TCO related things in
there definitely say to check it out but
in general yeah there's there's a big
TCO story from just a you have this much
you're like paying for this many
instances versus this many instances and
then if you're on Prem that number just
goes up higher especially because
there's a story about like I can reduce
my thousand plus node cluster to like 10
nodes in some situations and like the
amount of time effort and money that
goes into like managing a cluster of
that size versus managing 10 machines
that could be like a grad student at
that point so so yeah
yeah yeah yeah so tensorflow is a
struggle because tensorflow kind of goes
and does their own thing all over with
pi torch chain er MX net paddle paddle
everything is pretty straightforward and
I can show you real quick yeah that go
back to this notebook create a gdf data
frame here alright so I've got my cou DF
data frame I can call to DL pack on it
that returns me a PI capsule of a DL
tensor I can immediately go hand this to
essentially almost all of the deep
learning frameworks and they can read
that zero copy and immediately
immediately start training inferencing
whatever they want to do with it on it
and the same thing that essentially you
do stuff there and then you want to hand
it back there is a cootie F from DL pack
that basically converts from a DL pack
tensor to a cootie F object very nice
and tidy um the other thing I would add
is that basically if you have a column
here what you can do is basically
there's something called the CUDA array
interface which I touched on earlier
which is basically just like a standard
metadata description that basically
describes what the data on the GPU looks
like so you can see it has the shape the
type string a pointer to my data and
basically just like a version number
that describes it and a lot of libraries
have started using this where like
number cou pi pi torch MPI for pi and I
think a couple others supports this CUDA
Rae interface as well and that allows
you to Interop really easily and it's
it's basically modeled after the numpy
array interface but for GPUs yes
yep
yep not a data frame because each column
is a separate memory allocation but
shoving a column absolutely in CUDA rate
interface will just simply like they'll
say oh this object has CUDA rate
interface I can implicitly just handle
it
DL pack is explicit because it has
different semantics where essentially
the DL pack model is that if I export
something to D to DL pack and then that
that capsule gets used the original
memory is no longer valid so it has to
be explicit there yeah I don't have a
good number as for what percentage of
the API is like just because figuring
out the full scope of the panda's API is
a little bit tricky I would say that in
general it's at the point now where
we're not really getting we're not
getting a ton of feature requests for
like you're missing this API implement
this API in general like the majority of
like things that people use on a day to
day basis we have the API for I don't
I'm sure that we're missing keyword
arguments and places and we like don't
support using like a specific method
under the hood that may be like for
example doing like a forward fill fill
in a for example I'm sure there's like
places like that that we don't support
in general we we haven't our approach
hasn't been like here's the full total
footprint of the panda's API in every
single permutation of that API our
approach has been like what do our users
need to solve problems let's go build
what they need to go solve their
problems and basically rely on feedback
from the community to drive what we
should prioritize feature wise it'll
throw an exception
we use we use pandas quite a bit
internally but like not for the actual
computation side for like the control
flow data type handling type stuff
inside it
in general no just because then if
someone does something and then all of a
sudden they slow down it's not clear why
that like if a user wants to do pandas
things it's a one-liner to like go back
to pandas and that typically what we see
is that hey if there's a gap there
because there's like somewhat
easy-to-use UDF's that are performant
users can typically work around it
pretty easily as well and then in
general just we we really want the
feedback to say like hey we we use this
could you implement this in cou DF the
last thing we want is like someone to
call something and then it's all of a
sudden they're like hey this actually
ran slower than pandas maybe this cou DF
thing doesn't make sense so there any
other questions well thanks everyone
thank you for having me